اذا بالتاكيد مشاهدينا تابعتم تطورات
وعواج نبوثها اتباعا على شاشتنا اذا اعلن
الجيش السوداني قبل قليل بانه
بصدد نشر الالاف من القوات المسلحه وجهاز
المخابرات وايضا الاحتياطيه المركزي من
اجل القيام بعمليه مسح بريء لكامل ولايه
الخرطوم وكان قد اضاف الجيش السوداني ايضا
بان عمليه المسح هذه تاتي بعدما وصفها
بنجاح عمليه حسم جوي استهدفت النقاط وجود
قوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم فجر اليوم
قوات الدعم السريع من جهتها اكدت انه في
اول ايام العيد تستفيق الخرطوم على وقع
قنابل الطائرات والمدافع الثقيله في هجوم
كاسح كما وصفته من الجيش
استهدف الاحياء السكنيه هذه الان صور
مباشره تاتينا من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم ولمعرفه التطورات فيها على الارض
ينضم الي مراسلنا عبد البا قي الظافر
مرحبا عبد الباقي تشير هذه التصريحات بان
هناك حاله من الاضطراب الامني في الخرطوم
كيف هي الاوضاع بحسب مشاهداتك
نعم هذه محمد هذه التطورات الجديده تشير
ان الحرب انتقلت في اليوم الاول للعيد الى
مرحله مرحله جديده وهي مرحله المواجهات
البريه حينما تتحدث القوات المسلحه بانها
سوف
تنتشر بريا هذا يعني ان المعارك انتقلت من
المرحله الاولى هي كانت مرحله منع وصول
الدعم السريع الى الولايه الخرطوم عبر
استخدام سلاح الطيران وهو سلاح حسب
الخبراء ان القوات المسلحه تمتلك فيه ميزه
نسبيه باعتبار انها تمتلك سلاح الجو فعال
هذه هذه المرحله مرحله مرحله صعبه وفق
المراقبين لانها تعني تجدد وزياده
المواجهات داخل الاحياء السكنيه وايضا
تعني هذه المرحله ان الاطراف تحاول بسرعه
ان تحسم المعركه وتحسم المواجهه وحتى هذه
اللحظات
ليست لدينا معلومات عن
عن بدايه العمليه البريه اذا جاز لنا
التعبير ولكنني استطيع ان انقل الان وفق
معلومات من اطراف عديده واطراف مستغله
وذات حياديه الصوره صوره
التوازن القوه داخل الاولات الخرطوم قوات
الدعم السريع ما زالت منتشره في محيط حي
المطار خاصه الناحيه الغربيه من حي النطار
وهي
في هذا المكان كان مقر اقامه قائد قوات
الدعم في الناحيه الغربيه وفي الناحيه
الشرقيه اقامه رئيس مجلس السياده والقائد
العام للجيش وايضا لديهم سيطره نسبيه على
بعض الشوارع في الخرطوم شرق
ومنطقه الخرطوم اثنين ومنطقه الخرطوم
ثلاثه فيما القوات المسلحه تمسك من
المناطق الكبرى حول الخرطوم ومناطق
العسكريه القصر الجمهوري ما زالت بيد قوات
الدعم السريع تحدثنا الى خبراء عن
ماذا سيحدث في هذا اليوم الاول والايام
التاليه من مرحله
المواجهات على مستوى الاحياء هذه مرحله
صعبه ايضا ما يزيد صعوبه ان الدعم السريعه
قد ادخلت سلاح جديد وله فاعليه وهي سلاح
الدراجات الناريه وهي يعني الدراجه ناريه
استغلال شخصان او احيانا الثلاث اشخاص
مزودين باسلحه خفيفه واسلحه
سريعه وهذه
تمكنهم من الحركه بسرعه
وبسهوله والدخول في الشوارع الضيقه وتصعب
مهمه اوقات مسلحه وفق الخبراء في اقتناصهم
في هنالك ايضا استراتيجيه
قال لنا خبراء عسكريين لغات المسلحه
استخدمتها وتستخدمها بفاعليه وهي الاطباق
على الخصم من نواحي عديده ومحاوله تحليله
وهذه الاستراتيجيه بدات الان بخطاب سياسي
غير الخطاب العسكري الذي كانت تتحدث به
لغات المسلحه وهي تمييز بين القوات وفتح
استيعاب
حرس الحدود وهو جزء ومكون اساسي من القوات
الدعم السريع في القوات المسلحه لاعتبارا
من الامس وكذلك الحديث
عن ان الذي اقترن باعلان العفو عن قواعد
الدعم السريع وعن شروط التسويه البرهان
قال البارحه ان شروط التسويه بالنسبه لهم
لا تشمل العوده الى الوضع الذي استبق
قياما المعارك يوم السبت الماضي هنالك
ايضا نقطه مهمه تحصلنا عليها من خلال
تواصلنا مع الطرفين وهي الرصاصه الاولى من
اطلق الرصاصه الاولى ما تجمع على الذين من
معلومات ان الجيش السوداني اعتبر تحرق
قوات الدعم السريع بدون
تنسيق معه الى منطقه كان عمل عسكري وبدايه
للمعارك وفي ليله الجمعه او قبل السبت
قامت القوات المسلحه بحصار قوات في منطقه
ارض المعسكرات وكان لكنهم لم يكونوا
يتوقعون الامور
تنتهي الى مواجهه الشامله كانوا يعتقدون
كذلك سيكون كرت او بطاقه ضغط
واتجاه التصرفات التي حدثت في منطقه مروي
لكن بعدها اندلع
قتال كثير من قبل الدعم السريع وهو ما
يفسر ان الراتب السريع تمكنت بحسب هؤلاء
من عدد من ضباط الجيش السوداني لانها
اللحظه الاولى هي التي كانت بيد قوات
الدعم السريع اكثر من قوات الجيش السوداني
هذه الروايه تفسر لنا الان الواقع وتفسر
لنا ايضا امكانيه تقديم تنازلات
المرحله بتاعه الحرب البريه تاخذ وقت طويل
وربما تنتهي الى الشكل من اشكال
التفاوض
رئيس مجلس السياده والقائد العام لم يمتنع
عن حوار وخواضع له شروط وقال هي العوده
الى ما قبل مرحله انتشار قوات الدعم
السريع داخل الخرطوم وخارج الولايات اللغه
الاخرى ايضا في الدعم السريع لم ترفض
الحوار مطلقا ولكنها تشترط لو صحيح ربما
وضعت
وضعت سقوف عليا لهذا الحوار ولكن مجرد
القبول المبدئي بامكانيه وجود حوار بين
الطرفين ايضا ربما يكون هذا الضوء في اخر
النفق
مساله اخيره مهمه جدا وهي النواحي
الانسانيه يعني حدث تحسن في امداد
الكهرباء حدث تحسن في امداد المياه
وذلك ارتبط ايضا
السودانيين على التعايش مع القتال والعيش
في ظلال المعرفه لكن ما زالت هنالك عدد
كبير من المدنيين عالقين في مناطق القتال
ظروفهم صعبه تلقينا مناشدات عن بعض
المدنيين في فندق الاوكروبول وما جاوره في
وفي حي المطار مدني يقولون انهم يعيشون في
ظروف صعبه لا مياه لا طعام وهذا اليوم
الاول يوم العيد كان من المامون وكان من
المتوقع في اليوم الاول لايام عيد الفطر
المبارك ان يتمتع الجميع بهدنه وهدنه
نسبيه حتى يستطيعوا ان يتواصلوا حتى
يستطيع ان يبداوا مرحله جديده من التعايش
مع حرب لم يدفها لسنوات طويله
ويستطيع ان يدبروا ويتدبروا امورهم الى في
مستقبل الايام التي تربح في حكم المجهول
لكثير من الاسر السودانيه في مختلف
الارجاع وايضا يسمح بمساحه
جهود الدوليه ولجهود الجهود الداخليه في
محاوله اجبار الطرفين للعوده الى طاوله
الحوار ولكن مع ارتفاع حده العدائيات يصبح
هذا الامر حتى هذه اللحظه غير متوقع
بالعكس تكون ايام العيد فيها زياده لحده
الاعمال العسكريه اكثر من خفضها حسب
معلوماتنا وحسب ما تتمخض عنه العمليات
العسكريه الجاريه في هذه اللحظات محمد